there we go
um briefly i'll uh talk today in my part
about the program
and uh just to remind you you know what
is the goal of this program and what is
this program actually going to be
focused on so we're going to talk about
some of the tools methods and data
repositories
we'll talk about some of the curated
examples and peer-reviewed publications
that you should try to go through
during this program
we'll
go through some tools so that you can
start analyzing data and you know where
to find the relevant resources
and importantly we'll talk about the
relationship between how data is
generated how it is processed how it's
analyzed how it's visualized and
presented to describe a specific
infectious disease or potentially how it
develops and what are the outcomes
we'll also talk about how as a part of
this program hopefully you will have the
opportunity to develop an independent
research project
and then present it to some mentors for
feedback
so
the program will talk about
tools that are commonly used and we'll
focus on that first so we'll talk about
things like sequence variation how to
align sequences how to
characterize the variation we'll talk
about evolutionary analysis and how to
link
mutation rates and time but we'll also
talk about the specific applications of
those in different domains and
importantly subsequence variation so
subconsensus variation sorry
we'll talk about functionality and
protein structure how a lot of the
sequences that we'll be dealing with are
protein coding sequences and that's why
we can explore interaction between
different proteins and try to understand
what can we learn about the impact of a
particular variation on the the function
on how those interact
and then we'll also talk about
transcriptomic data analysis because
when we think about the infection uh the
viral or bacterial genome is what kind
of characterizes that infectious
pathogen but we're also interested in
the human response or host response and
we can characterize that really well
with transcriptomic data including
balkan or single cell rna-seq so we'll
talk a little bit about that as well
today though what are we going to try to
achieve today so first of all i will
kind of use this pandemic to talk about
bioinformatics and infectious diseases
and we'll talk a little bit about how
this pandemic really highlights the
application of bioinformatics tools
but we'll also talk about how it uh
guides the development in population
health how people are thinking about
epidemiology and also the development of
vaccines and antiviral drugs and
we'll talk about how this online program
can work in the best way possible for
you based on your background based on
your interests based on your objectives
and goals where can you find the
necessary resources for you to be
successful and what can you expect to
get out of this program
so as solene already mentioned
the central
location where you will find all of the
resources that you need is going to be
on this onyx logic portal
and what we'll do first is we'll make
sure that everybody is set up to do
everything that you need to do
throughout the program by completing
your sign up and your profile
so how many of you already have a
completed profile
all right anu did you complete your
profile already
okay let me show you
what a completed profile looks like
and then we will jump into our exercises
so here
if i log in to
learnomicslogic.com you can see that i'm
logged in i can click on my name
and that will be my profile
so you should be able to recognize me
hopefully look as beautiful as i do on
this profile picture
uh if you want to connect with me uh
you're welcome to connect with me on
twitter
on linkedin
uh also see my work id
right here and what i can do
is i can share with you my profile just
by clicking
right here on top and sharing my url
so as we're going to be going through
this program as a team as a group
let's make sure that we have all of
these profiles completed if something is
not complete you can just click on your
profile and right here you can add all
of that information make sure that you
include the full link to your account if
you want to share your social tool and
if you are not comfortable with
uploading your own picture
you don't think it looks that great you
can just put a logo or maybe some
picture and that will help us see that
you've completed it actually it's going
to be important for you to be able to
work on an independent project
all right so i see that
um
clement has completed
and
i understand uh anu
also
did anyone else
all right anaga thank you
if you have uh please share the link to
your profile
so we'll save that for later we'll be
able to follow up
[Music]
all right briefly i'll show you what you
can do with this profile uh you'll be
able to go through different courses as
we go through the program and these
courses are going to be related to
different topics that we cover for
example infectious pathogens like
malaria evt 68 sars cove 2 all of them
have an associated publication with a
data set with some tutorial that you can
go through
and that is a part of this curriculum so
as you go through
and you want to go back to where you
left off
sorry you can always see
that information right here
your objective throughout this program
is to get to 10 000 points so you can
see that i've been doing this for a
while i have over 26 000 points but all
you need to do is actually get to the 10
000 points and 10 000 points will allow
you to work on an independent project
so
that project here i have some demo
examples but you'll be able to actually
start a new project and this is like
preparing for a publication so you'll be
able to use this as a poster
presentation we by the way have an
online virtual symposium at the end of
the summer that you're welcome to
participate in that but really how do
you demonstrate that you've learned
something in bioinformatics for
infectious diseases the answer is you do
it by showing showcasing your work and
showcasing your work also provides you
with the benefit of connecting with
mentors and experts in the field that
can comment and suggest improvements to
your project so this is a critical
component of this program and i'm really
hoping that you will be able to do this
now if you have a question throughout
this program
about the data sets about the right
kinds of research questions all of that
information we actually have a course on
that
uh and so one of the requirements for
anyone who would like to complete a
research project is number one
to have a completed profile
number two to get to at least 10 000
points and number three is to complete
this course course nine designing a
bioinformatics research project
[Music]
so
why is this so important
this is important because
our objective throughout this program is
to help you learn about bioinformatics
and in application to infectious
diseases but also to acquire practical
skills
and one way that we can know that you
have acquired those practical skills is
of course to ask you uh but if we just
ask you and you tell us there's really
no depth to that understanding so that's
why we design our process in the
learning of omics data and analytics
by structuring our content from
basic understanding the terminology
understanding examples understanding
what we're talking about all the way to
this independent thinking and ability to
construct an analytical process
by understanding what analysis matches
what kind of data
matching what kind of question
and all of those things are kind of
integrated on this online portal
so here's just some example of
recent graduates who have completed our
program you can see that
a couple of them have been able to cross
that 10 000 points but not everyone has
and that's okay because really the
objective here is to fit the program to
your needs and not the other way around
i hope that all of you would be able to
complete an independent project but if
you're not ready for that and you need
more time that's okay as well
but i do think that at least you should
be able to understand the terminology at
the end of this program
and showcase what you have learned and
that's why we have certificates
for each course that you will complete
we have examples so you can see how
these methods are applied in different
types of infectious disease studies or
experiments
and you will be able
and sorry you'll be able to at least do
some literature review and kind of read
through the methods of these
publications and really understand what
others are doing
so before we go on i'll introduce myself
and another mentor that you will work
with throughout this program dr uh
raghav lakshmi narayan
uh my name is elia
uh
really i'm a manager but i do have
bioinformatics experience my background
is in applied mathematics and data
science and i'm currently doing my mba
but really i want to tell you about the
reason why
i'm interested in bioinformatics for
infectious diseases
and then if anyone would like to share a
little bit more about your background
and why you've joined this program and
what your goals are i'll uh kind of
you know
allocate some time for that
so uh right before the pandemic
i
was invited to participate in a project
that was uh financed by darpa
and actually before the project that i
participated in there was another
project that we kind of applied for a
grant funding to uh participate in and
that project was called prophecy
uh now prophecy sounds like you know
this
uh interesting name
uh practically speaking what they were
trying to do is they were trying to
develop
um
a combination of experimental techniques
and analytical and mathematical modeling
techniques to be able to predict which
viruses
might uh break out might cause a
an epidemic or a pandemic
and how that pandemic is likely to
um kind of spread
so that original project i thought was
you know very fascinating idea uh we
applied for funding we kind of you know
thought about different types of tools
and methods and mathematical modeling
that can help us in that
ultimately we did not participate in
that original project but we reapplied
again in the next term
and that project was focused on a
therapeutic prevention of such an
outbreak so remember this is all before
the pandemic started no one is thinking
coronaviruses no one is thinking covet
but everybody in the group uh you know
these were people from stanford from
ucsf from nyu from all of these uh great
medical research centers and everyone
was
proposing their set of viruses so there
were people that dealt with ebola virus
and with nipah and with all kinds of hiv
and other types of
epidemic and pandemic type viruses
and
as i saw them interact it really drew me
into this whole topic because i realized
that
we kind of live in a world where
viruses bacteria pathogens
they
are out of the site until something
really terrible happens and uh we don't
you know all of these people they were
complaining about lack of funding and
lack of uh you know focus and attention
to what they were developing and lack of
kind of public health policy about these
infectious diseases and and right
towards the end of that project is when
this pandemic actually started and and
that was just amazing to come into this
pandemic with so much understanding of
actually what's going on
what kinds of tools and methods and
ongoing research is going on and it
really allowed me to appreciate the work
that a lot of these research scientists
were doing at the time and i even
remember
after the pandemic kind of started to
subside i went back to the gym
and one of the people that we worked
with on this project became kind of a
more prominent uh public figure speaking
about the pandemic and the research that
they were doing
at university of pittsburgh and and i
kind of knew the guy you know and we
worked together and things like that so
it was really an interesting uh paradigm
shift for me uh going into that project
and then eventually kind of seeing how
the pandemic unfolded and is continuing
to unfold
so that's my personal story um of how i
got interested in bioinformatics for
infectious diseases specifically
uh is there anyone else that would like
to share kind of you know why did you
think to join this program now and and
what would you like to achieve as a part
of your training
i'll just give it a moment if anybody
wants to
i'd love to hear
if not that is also fine
yes
go ahead uh
hola cano
uh yeah my name is alcano i come from
kenya
um
i've been following a couple of uh
our youtube
uh webinars from pine
uh biotech
and i've seen the quality of the work
that they are representing
which is in line with
what i really want to pursue in future
in terms of applying
bioinformatics and infectious diseases
my background is in
our chemistry
and i really want to
at some point
get experience also in
looking at
uh
the aspect of drug discovery in
for instance malaria
yeah because in
in tropical countries like sub-saharan
africa
infectious disease is a public health
concern
yeah so i want to work at the interface
of
looking at
uh nobel
drugs that are sourced from natural
products
and now understand that from
bioinformatics point of view
and i've seen that i might get that kind
of skills
uh set of i mean skill set
from uh fine
from this company
excellent
yeah thank you holy cow and definitely a
very concerning and a big topic to
address there so thank you very much
hope that you know you achieve your
goals and
we'll probably have a chance to interact
more about that
so let's give a chance to clement
clement uh would you like to share your
uh background and
how
you'd like to use this time
yeah greetings from nigeria my name is
clement
i fell in love with bioinformatics after
attending a series of webinars
like my
colleague from kenya just said
i
came across this training in one tele
telegram group
and
i appreciate the administrator for the
whatsapp group too
who decided to mentor me on this
after about 29 years of bench work
i just took up an
academic appointment and one of the
topics
listed by the faculty is bioinformatics
so i really look forward to
learning
the intricacies the applications
the foundation of bioinformatics thank
you very much it's nice being with you
all
thanks
excellent excellent thank you clement
thank you very much
okay great so again we'll have more
opportunity to um connect with each
other and and get to know each other so
please um you know continue to share
your links to your profile that's really
i think the easiest way for us to
connect in the beginning but let us
switch gears and we'll briefly talk
about some of the tools that we're going
to be using in this program and i want
to give you a little bit of an
illustration today as well
so you kind of get a sense of where
we're going uh what might be the
potential outcome towards the end what
you would acquire as a result of going
through this program
so we're going to be using
these three primary resources
one of them is going to be the onyx
logic portal and as i showed already and
sononika showed in the beginning we will
have
project examples curated data sets
some training materials that everyone
will have the opportunity to go through
the second portal is going to be the t
bioinfo platform and has some dedicated
sections designed to facilitate the
types of studies that we will go through
and those include processing analysis
visualization of different types of
analytical methods like multiple
sequence alignment phylogeny
transcriptomic data analysis integration
machine learning and others and then we
will also learn a little bit about
coding in both r and python now coding
is like a language and you know once
you've started you can really start
speaking about anything that you would
like
but one of the important parts of
you know coding ex
exercises that we will do in this
program are going to be related to
the methods that we first cover on the
platform so you understand the logic
first why are we doing what we're doing
how do we get from a to b
and then we will look at typically some
packages that somebody already prepared
and we'll focus on the application so
we're not going to spend too much time
on the algorithmic part the mathematics
of these methods but if you would like
to you're welcome we will share some
publications and some links where you
can read more about all of those methods
okay so again we don't have that much
time left but
what first i want to do in this first
part of this presentation is briefly
talk about some of the traditional and
novel methods and bioinformatics used
for infectious disease research and i
want to give you some examples that
include working with high throughput
sequencing data
how to detect and characterize a viral
strain and also the relationship between
nucleotide and amino acid and the
mapping of sequence variation on protein
structures so these are some things that
we'll kind of go through